y la ideología de la agresión y de odio
fue aplastada y la experiencia de la
alianza así como también conocimiento
del precio que se había pagado por la
paz y por la victoria ayudó a construir
el orden mundial posguerra fundó los
pilares de las naciones unidas y que hoy
aún nos rigen a nivel mundial estoy
convencido que esto
y formulando por los fundadores de
nuestra organización
en los términos más ambiguos esto
incluye de la soberanía la no
interferencia en los
los derechos para terminar su futuro
el no uso de la fuerza
mirando la última década uno puede decir
que a pesar de todas las dificultades de
las de la guerra fría y todos los
cambios que se han hecho aquí nos han
llevado a la política de hoy la onu ha
logrado mantener la paz promover
el desarrollo sostenible
de las personas y los continentes y
proveyendo asistencia para evitar una
crisis global
esta experiencia de la onu sirve como
una base sólida para el futuro así como
otra organización internacional o
entidad regional la onu no debe
evolucionar de acuerdo con la dinámica
del siglo 21
y adaptarse a adaptarse al mundo moderno
pero cada vez es más complicado
ya que es multidimensional y multi
multicolor
así como el debate
sobre la reforma de el consejo de
seguridad de las naciones unidas debe
ser más inclusivo para todos los países
así como la diversidad de sus posiciones
basado en nuestros bajos de los
conceptos entre los estados y al mismo
tiempo continuar sirviendo como una base
para la gobernanza global
si no se puede
mientras los estados miembros mantengan
su poder de veto
lo más importante es un instrumento
único y esencial que ayuda a prevenir
las acciones unilaterales que pueden
resultar en una confrontación militar
entre grandes estados y provee una
oportunidad
para evitar solucionados que debe ser
inaceptable para otros
y evitar una terreno gris de
arbitrariedades
este instrumento funciona
no
cómo
aquellas declaraciones sin tienen
mecanismos para una acción segura y para
resolver la ayuda a las personas más
necesitadas
así es
cómo interpretar las causas politizar
las causas
y usar las causas de segunda guerra
mundial para cambiar a las decisiones
son las conferencias
no es sólo algo vil y una ofensa para
sus víctimas
un golpe a las las bases del orden
mundial actual
los conflictos regionales que siguen sin
solucionarse las amenazas del terrorismo
el crimen organizado y el narcotráfico
se han intensificado también estamos
experimentando un nuevo reto con la
pandemia de coronavirus está afectado
miles de personas
y ha cobrado la vida de cientos de miles
de personas las cuarentenas a cerrar las
fronteras una serie de problemas para
los ciudadanos de casi todos los estados
constituye la actualidad ha sido
bastante difícil para las personas
mayores quien debido a las restricciones
no han podido abrazar a sus seres
queridos a sus hijos o nietos por
semanas incluso por meses en los
expertos
han aumentado
el costo de la pandemia y las
consecuencias a largo plazo pero también
es evidente que va a tomar mucho mucho
tiempo restaurar la economía global más
aún
las prevenciones no van a funcionar
siempre tendremos
una solución definitiva tenemos que
elaborar para lograr estas soluciones y
trabajar en conjunto lo cual debe ser lo
más importante para la onu y para el g20
así como para otras entidades
internacionales o asociaciones
integrales
y fundamentalmente necesitan nuevos
horizontes para el desarrollo está ahí
de esta idea del crecimiento
uno de los que detrás de los intereses
de rusia
ayudando a los países de asia y de
europa
es muy importante a pesar además
debemos crear los corredores verdes y
cine libres de sanciones y
para un libre comercio para el paso de
comida de alimentos de medicamentos para
poder luchar contra esta pandemia
eliminar las sanciones y bloqueos sería
vital para evitar el aumento del
desempleo de acuerdo a los expertos la
reducción total o parcial en cuanto al
empleo en el segundo cuarto de este año
es igual
a la pérdida de 400 millones de empleos
y debemos evitar que este desempleo
aumenta a un término a largo plazo
y que las personas puedan regresar para
mantener y sostener a sus familias esto
es un problema esencial
la pandemia también ha señalado unos
problemas éticos éticos tecnológicos y
humanitarios por ejemplos el avance
tecnológico ha logrado que los estudios
se puedan adaptar a este
la inteligencia artificial ha ayudado a
los doctores ya los médicos para lograr
una tratamiento adecuado y rápido pero
como cualquier otra cosa esto se expande
se expande sin control y así como las
armas pueden caer en las manos de
extremistas radicales
no solo en países en riesgo sino en
países en todos los países en general
en cuanto a la ciberseguridad y el uso
de la tecnología avanzada deben servir
es una gran deliberación en la onu es
importante escuchar las preocupaciones
de las personas sobre los derechos de la
privacidad propiedad y seguridad en la
nueva era debemos aprender a usar esta
tecnología para el beneficio de la
humanidad para buscar un balance entre
el desarrollo de la inteligencia
artificial y las restricciones para así
también limitar la a trabajar conjunto
para lograr las regulaciones para evitar
una amenaza a nivel militar
y de seguridad tecnológica
así
quiero enseñar que durante la pandemia
los doctores voluntarios
se ha mostrado la solidaridad entre
todos los trabajadores de la salud los
países se ayudan unos a otros
pero han habido algunos casos que
mostraron un déficit de la humanidad y
si ustedes quieren ver en la
a nivel interestatal también creemos que
el prestigio de la onu
debe ayudar en estas relaciones
bilaterales para ayudar entre las
culturas entre programas de educación
así como la exportación de corporaciones
ciencia tecnología medioambiente y en la
protección de la salud
así como una economía el sector de la
salud
ayudando a las personas y a los estados
más vulnerables a nivel bilateral y con
formatos multilaterales haciéndolo así
es mucho
y creemos que es esencial fortalecer la
capacidad de lado ms este trabajo ya se
empezó a hacer y rusia está motivado en
participar en ella construir en la
industria
clínica rusia ha desarrollado un sistema
de ensayos para detectar y tratar el
coronavirus así como registrar la
primera vacuna
5 estamos completamente abiertos para
lograr una alianza
con corporaciones en este contexto
hemos realizado
relaciones con los países que están
interesados en esta vacuna incluyendo en
darles la vacuna rusa que ha probado ser
sana salva y efectiva en otros países
rusia está segura que todas las
capacidades de la industria tecnológica
y de ciencia
de proveer para que debe proveer a todos
los países y estados sobre para esta
vacuna el coronavirus
afecta a todas las estructuras y
organizaciones así como todo el mundo
rusia ha apoyado a la onu
y estamos dispuestos a entregar la
vacuna gratis al estas y la gente de la
onu hemos ofrecido nuestra asistencia y
ayudas y conocimiento
hay otros problemas críticos en la
agenda la protección del medio ambiente
y el cambio climático debe ser el foco
de nuestros esfuerzos
y las convenciones de la onu los
tratados los acuerdos y protocolos han
mostrado ser efectivos estamos llamando
a todos los estados en comprometerse con
ellos particularmente en trabajar para
lograr el objetivo del acuerdo de parís
queridos colegas quiero subrayar que
rocío hacer todos los esfuerzos para
lograr una resolución política
diplomática y humanitaria en lugares de
conflictos
a veces son tiempos en que
no hay confianza
y seguiremos ayudando las iniciativas
para controlar la propagación de armas
esto incluye la prohibición de armas
químicas nucleares o tóxicas
la importancia de el tema es sobre la
extensión de la reducción de armas entre
eeuu y rusia
estamos comprometidos en las
negociaciones con nuestros aliados
estadounidenses sobre este tema también
esperamos que se será algo mutuos en
cuanto al sistema de misiles
el año pasado rusia declaró
una moratoria entre
el sistema de largo y corto y medio
alcance en europa pero no hemos recibido
una respuesta a nuestra propuesta por
parte de eeuu o sus aliados
nuestra propuesta
daría unas bases oportunas para el
lanzamiento y los posibles efectos que
tengan estos lanzamientos
logrando una fundación
y unas bases fuertes para la seguridad
internacional
y
para el futuro político militar y social
rusia promueve un acuerdo entre todos
los líderes espaciales
para
acordar establecer armas en el lugar
espacial
también llamamos a esfuerzos en común
que debería hacer unirnos recordar la
historia
y resaltar la alianza y las coaliciones
de los participantes y es posible
superar las preferencias de ideas las
diferencias ideológicas y enfocarnos en
los intereses del mundo
todos los países deben tener todo el
deseo para trabajar en ellos los
miembros permanentes del consejo de
seguridad de la onu por 75 años
han tenido la responsabilidad de
mantener la paz y seguridad del mundo
reservar la ley internacional y eso debe
prevalecer aquí rusia ha sugerido un eje
5 una reunión g5
para tratar el tema de la ley
internacional y manejar estos temas que
son claves en estos momentos es
importante que nuestros aliados nos
apoyen y esperamos que puedan asistir
si es que la pandemia lo permite
en un mundo interdependiente
necesitamos trabajar juntos unidos bajo
las normas de la ley internacional esta
es la única forma para seguir con la
misión de las naciones unidas y froome y
proveerle a las personas una vida
les deseo a todos paz
a todos y muchas gracias